joining us with reaction south carolina
senator lindsey graham
before i get to this i think one of your
finest moments in the u.s senate was
during the kavanaugh hearing and you had
had enough
now you've got all these new allegations
against governor cuomo
uh i don't know the truth of what i
don't know if these things are true
i thought the republican party frankly
for once actually
handled that situation with justice
kavanaugh the right way
okay serious allegations we're going to
stop pause and investigate
and they did and we found out a lot of
lies were told and you had had enough
i don't know the case here i believe in
due process presumption of innocence
senator
well number one the idea that cuomo
would
appoint his own investigator tells you a
lot about his mindset
so the democratic party is now piling on
andrew cuomo because he's made a lot of
enemies along the way but
you've been consistent and i've been
consistent we allowed dr ford to be
heard there were five accusations
against
justice kavanaugh three were literally
made up
and when it comes to dr ford i think
something happened to her
but i don't think brett kavanaugh had
anything to do with it
and all i'm asking my democratic
colleagues who believed every word dr
ford said
even before judge kavanaugh spoke and we
did an investigation
you're now giving cuomo a complete pass
schumer went on the floor of the senate
day in and day out accusing all of us
republicans
of supporting sexual assault have you
heard him say one word about this
so the double standard is pretty obvious
but the one thing that i can't
explain to you because you're not up
here i couldn't walk three feet during
the kavanaugh hearing without some
reporter sticking a microphone in my
face
what do you think about the new
accusation and the idea that that
kavanaugh was guilty was pervasive
the accusation was self-proving i
haven't had one person
ask me about the accusations against
governor cuomo from the media not one
all right there's serious allegations
made by tara reid
and and another woman out in nevada now
do we go back and take those allegations
seriously
in other words you had a whole i
believer caucus and the list of people
i'll scroll it again
that are silent now that was so vocal
then
is pretty darn long senator
well here's what i would tell my
democratic colleagues to do follow the
republican model
we had a republican nominee for the
supreme court be accused of something
the the day before we voted the moment
before we voted
we could have gone ahead saying this was
too late you said on it you didn't tell
us
this is not fair we stopped the entire
dim process
we had days and weeks of hearings we had
another fbi investigation
we took it seriously and what what
should you do as democrats regarding
cuomo
do exactly what republicans did call for
an independent investigation take it
seriously
all right let me move on we'll keep
scrolling the names because it's pretty
long so people can get the full picture
to the president's speech at cpac no
third party
america first agenda make america great
again agenda
mitch mcconnell to his credit right you
know said yeah
vote for him if he's the nominee okay
there are disagreements at times ronald
reagan famously said if we agree 80
of the time you're not my enemy is he
right yeah
yeah reagan was right i just talked to
president trump just a few minutes ago
and i said listen
um it's not necessary for everybody to
like each other
i actually like president trump he's
been very nice to me he's allowed me to
be in his world he allows me to give my
two cents worth about different issues
when he was president
this is his party if you don't get that
you missed a lot at cpac
donald trump has the nomination right
now and nobody can take it away from him
if he wants to run
and i think he's got a damn good chance
of getting re-elected again
based on what the democrats are doing to
the country but what i would tell
president trump
the real test for you and the republican
party is 2022.
let's make sure we have our best
candidates on the field
let's don't have primaries of people
who've been good republican
conservatives
let's unite and if we'll follow
president trump's lead
that we're going to be the united
republican party we're going to put our
best team
on the field in 2022 that sets the stage
for a 2024 comeback
we've got a lot of talented people in
the party sean did you
find one person at cpac criticized
donald trump
i thought it was amazing that you have
so many people wanting to be president
on our side
but not one person would say anything
bad about him that tells you a lot about
the strength of president trump
will you help me draft hershel walker to
run for senate down in georgia because i
happen to be very fond of him
now talk to him today stay tuned